[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, everyone.
We're here the
Infrastructure and Migration
Zone of Google Cloud Next.
I'm Mark Mirchandani.
I'm here with Srinath.
Srinath, we heard a
lot today about Anthos.
What is Anthos?
Why is it so exciting?
SRINATH PADMANABHAN: Anthos
is incredibly exciting for us
at Google Cloud.
We announced Anthos as
Cloud Services Platform
just over eight months ago.
And today, we're very
excited to announce
general availability of
Anthos for our customers
to be able to use it.
Anthos is our Hybrid
and Multi-Cloud Platform
that gives our
customers the ability
to build once and run anywhere.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Why is
Hybrid and Multi-Cloud
so important right now?
SRINATH PADMANABHAN: That's
a great question, Mark.
So hybrid and Multi-Cloud
has been on top of mind
for a lot of our customers.
They're very, very excited
about the ability to use clouds.
But oftentimes what happens is
when they're running something
on-prem but running
something else in the cloud,
it becomes hard
for them to manage
these different
deployments that make
them segment their workforce
into engineers who are working
on different things instead
of focusing on innovating
for their customers.
So that's why Hybrid and
Multi-Cloud is very important.
And it's very important to have
a uniform platform like Anthos
that lets customers run in a
uniform way across the board.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So we're
talking about standardizing,
making sure that everyone's
on the same level.
For people who are
here at the showcase,
they can come interact
with this booth.
What does this tell
people who are looking
at what does Anthos do for me?
SRINATH PADMANABHAN: So
what we have in this demo
is we've taken the analogy
of a city and how it works,
and we've used that to show
how Hybrid and Multi-Cloud is
very important and
how Anthos helps
in that particular analogy.
So let's get started.
So we have these three
things that you can do over
the course of this demo.
First, let's start off by
modernizing your services.
There are multiple
reasons you would
want to modernize your service.
For instance, it gives you
a lot more agility and speed
and lets you deploy faster.
So in this demo,
there are two options
for how you can modernize
your applications.
You can either
containerize them manually
or you can use
CSP Migrate, which
is now called Anthos
Migrate, to be
able to migrate these
applications automatically
from VMs running on-prem
into containers running
in the cloud.
So for the sake of
this run-through,
let's select Modernizing
with Velostrata,
which is Anthos Migrate.
So Velostrata
automatically containerizes
your VM-based workload
and will deploy them
to GKE running in the cloud.
So just as easily as that,
you'll have all of you
a VMs now move to the
cloud as containers.
Now, let's look at
the second part.
We also help you standardize
config management
using Anthos Config Management.
What Anthos Config
Management lets you do
is it lets you take a
single configuration
and deploy it across the board,
declaratively and uniformly,
without you having to go and do
it once at a time per platform.
So no matter whether you're
running only on-prem,
in Google Cloud, or maybe
even with other clouds,
you can do this all at once.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So now it's all standardized.
SRINATH PADMANABHAN: So
now it's all standardized.
And so for the third
part of this demo,
there's something
very exciting for me,
which is a service mesh.
A service mesh is
basically a mechanism
that lets you look deep into the
traffic that's actually flowing
between your applications,
whether they're
on on-premise or in the cloud.
In this case, what
we're going to do
is we're going to use Anthos
to implement a service
mesh between on-prem
world here and the two
cloud worlds that we have.
And by doing this, we're
able to select a service
and we're able to say that
let's upgrade the service.
Now, when you
upgrade the service,
you pick a new version that you
want to upgrade to, but instead
of upgrading everything at
once, what you're going to do
is you're going to select a
small percentage off your VMs
or workloads and
upgrade them at once.
So when you do this and you
upgrade these containers
at that point in time, you
will upgrade just that 20%.
So that you see everything
is running fine,
and you don't have
anything broken.
And once you are confident that
this service is working well,
you can upgrade everything else.
So this means now you're
able to roll out applications
with limited downtime to almost
0 downtime for your customers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So you can see how
Anthos uses open source
technologies but also
this idea of standardization to
really bring it to everybody.
SRINATH PADMANABHAN: Yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What's
an example customer
or concrete use case that
Anthos has right now?
SRINATH PADMANABHAN:
Great question.
So we have a lot of
customers who have been
very excited to use Anthos.
And they span
multiple verticals.
Like, for instance, HSBC
from retail and banking
and Siemens who's a giant
when it comes to manufacturing
are also looking at Anthos
as their platform of choice
for doing IoT and
then IoT Platform.
So there are multiple
customers across verticals
like retail and
health care who are
very excited about
this platform and love
that ability to standardize
and have a uniform platform.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Perfect.
Well, thank you so much Srinath.
I'm sure there's going to be
tons of great content here
about Anthos and lots of other
stuff at Google Cloud Next
so stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]